hey guys this Jeff from wacky gamer you
had awesome Blizzcon nerd more
suggestions I'm really excited to go ask
the fans meanwhile go to Facebook that
wacky gamer calm and you can contribute
and see some of our pictures
I still have to go with Arthas Kerrigan
obviously because well when a woman's
angry can a man really ever stand a
chance yeah I would have to say cuz
she's a chick and she's such a badass it
has to be Kerrigan sticking out of her
Kerrigan because she's got boobs office
would be distracted he'd be like I
wasn't gonna go with Kerrigan but you
told me
Arthas cuz I don't know because I don't
play anything other than Wow so Arthas
kicks it kicks her ass any day although
I did see a smokin hot girl out here
dressed as as Kerrigan she was in the
costume contest holy [ __ ] hands down no
way Kerrigan would smokin that's not
true defiles that doesn't even matter
Kerrigan you can cut off a Carrigan's
lemon it'll grow right back she's got a
healing factor the vouchers would carry
her off the edge wings hello
doesn't matter you're like stunned when
yer get carried off by the vouchers yeah
but they drop you flying back I have
flame form is it druid and I never got
to fly back ok Kerrigan is not a druid
yeah she's an infested xored with a
healing factor she's a [ __ ]
George definitely they can res I think
Bruce Campbell will kick both their
asses so the army and the army of the
Dead is first in line discourage yet the
scourge would win easily I mean look at
is a joke right the army dead is just
funny
they're not real no they did it no ash
said the boomstick that would win
plus-plus army of the Dead is a movie
and World of Warcraft is real no
discouraged because they're persistent
yes little yeah I'd say the scourge
scourge never ends and it never will
they just keep coming and coming coming
so gonna have to go with them on that
one
we're gonna go with Deathwing why he's a
big angry dragon full of fire rage and
hate and Diablo well he's just kind of
got fire going for him I would have to
say death maybe because that guy is a
frickin masochist to have some people
just put all that petaled metal and play
it all over his body
that's just know he wins Deathwing raped
all of all of Azeroth it's all [ __ ] up
because of him
Diablos a god death wings a dragon with
metal on his face versus a god immortal
I did not see Diablo [ __ ] up all of
Azeroth did you yeah but you know what
you can kill Diablo with a sword whereas
Deathwing actually has like metal plates
with spikes dis long like applied to his
body he can take the sword yes but can
you kill Diablo has Diablo come back
three times yeah how many times his
death Wayne come back Deathwing is just
now making his first comeback yeah like
what is the bad seventies death wing
because he hasn't been killed yet I
would say Diablo because he is the I
guess he keeps getting who's the top of
all evil I mean Diablo is even lower
than death when death runs in the earth
but Diablo is in the Burning Hells so I
would say Diablo we disagree I agree to
disagree the first disagreement I think
Diablos he's past his prime you think
yeah what threes coming out Jasmine's
been in prison for 10,000 years
he's angry that's true
Dairy Queen's Blizzard because there's
Oreos she would eat the Dairy Queen
blizzard and then fear bomb everybody in
the house Dairy Queen blizzard cuz you
can't fight deliciousness I see what you
did there I would say that Dairy Queen's
blizzard because I don't know what that
is that oh you're the wizard is do you
know today they don't have Dairy Queen
in England no oh but I would say the
blizzard winds too because it's a tasty
treat yeah tasty ice cream retreat but
the thing is I know where the Blood
Queen she likes to bite you whereas with
the blizzard I'm assuming you like to
bite it so I'm gonna say I also see
where you did there - you know with all
kinds of people did they it's just crazy
creative how much of the Dairy Queen
Blood Queen hard brownish one in the
[ __ ] heart notes whereas Dairy Queen
blizzards those are [ __ ] delicious so
in other words you have to suck to
finish both of them so it's basically
ice crown versus ice cream Citadel the
puns just keep on coming in here